[Music]
jennifer stole my voice but if i get
someone let's do it hi i'm jennifer
hudson and this is the ultimate respect
playlist the first one is accentuate the
positive
she has this amazing super swingy
rendition of that song so that's the
first one
next georgia by emily king
autobiographical and ambiguous
simultaneously obviously i never loved a
man the way that i love you mahalia
jackson singing take my hand precious
lord you cannot have a respect playlist
that does not include mahalia jackson
because nahelia jackson meant so much to
the franklin family and to aretha's mom
natural woman think never loved a man i
could go on and on i'm gonna add i want
magic renee fleming her iconic
performance of nesundorma that was one
of the things that really influenced me
to train in opera curtis mayfield
because there's something very pimp
about him freddy's dead
pusher man the next one i picked is nina
simone feeling good just because it
reminds me of some of aretha's jazz
columbia recordings definitely sam cook
a change is gonna come and then there's
a song that i wrote called i took the
you out of me that helped me get rid of
negative energy my next one which is
jolene by dolly parton i just think that
she would have killed it if she sang
that song chain of fools
oh i love that song ain't no way because
i love hitting the high note
i hit it just not the key on the piano
that you're supposed to of course aretha
franklin's singing amazing grace my
parents would listen to this at least
once a week i gotta go with respect one
of the greatest anthems ever created
like how do you do a movie called
respect and you ain't play respect
r-e-s-b-e-c-t
and that's the ultimate respect playlist
you